there's a first method of um solution
and i don't know if it seemed okay to
you to follow that logic how i got it
out of the diagram and then just went
straight to try and compute things um i
i think this method works fine and it
certainly gets the two marks i'll come
back to question or the part two in a
second but i want to show you this other
way of solving it which as i said was
inspired by parhan um and i wonder if
you worked out why in that time let's
have a look at this result here right u
squared plus v squared equals uv i just
went straight to evaluating what is u
squared what is v squared what is uv i
just use these
particular forms to do it right
but i wonder if you look at this and if
you stare at it a bit longer whether it
actually looks familiar for another
reason
whether you can see a hold on a second
this u squared and v squared and uv
don't they come together in some other
results some other package that i've
seen before
i wonder if you recognize it yet i'm not
going to spoil it just yet let me see if
i've given you enough of a clue to see
where i can uh help you with that right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
come back here oopsies
i'm going to come back up to here and
i'm going to notice that uh u and v are
related by this pi on 3 anti-clockwise
rotation right so i'm trying to use
vector thinking in this form so when you
go from one to the other you can
actually state v
as sort of a different complex number in
terms of u do you see that like it
shares that same theta up there and it's
just that rotation so what i could do is
i could say
this thing here can also be written as v
multiplied by whatever will accomplish
that clock anticlockwise rotation of pi
on three radians which is e to the i pi
on three that that will do the um the
right uh magnitude of the argument for
me right so i can actually use this form
here of um sorry that's um
uh u and v together right i can actually
combine those together
to show how i'm going to get my u
squared plus b squared equals uv result
okay here's the way i'm going to write
it let's come down here get some new
space so i'm going to call this
method 2.
um what i can say is v is or what did i
say did i say this right uh
no no sorry this is not v times it's u
times that's what i started with uh this
is the original complex number and then
v gets to it by taking u uh and writing
v in terms of u so sorry about that uh
what can i say well i can say v is equal
to u times this e to the i pi on three
and then in order to get a um sort of
easier way to work with this right like
i can actually clear out all the complex
numbers uh very quickly or rather sort
of these
parts that i need to manipulate the
arithmetic of by cubing everything
you're like cubing mr wu why would we be
cubing things well watch right when i
cube the left hand side you just get v
cubed when i cube the right hand side
you get well this gets cubed
and then this also gets cubed but
because it's edi and three you're just
multiplying that index by three which is
e d i
pi
and the reason why this is useful is
because now that i have taken that um pi
on three which is up there in the argan
diagram right i've brought it back onto
the real axis so i can just evaluate it
in a very straightforward way and then
this is no longer a complex numbers
question right we've seen this before um
hundreds of times uh the way to make a
question easy to solve is to turn
something hard into something like the
same question but a different form
that's easier to manipulate and i bet
very few of you but i'd be interested to
see
okay yes sharma's just pointed it well
done um
i i can actually turn this complex
numbers question completely into a real
numbers question watch this right
edi pi
it starts from the positive real axis
and it cycles pi radians all the way to
the opposite side of the real axis so
it's just negative one and in fact this
is part of that famous euler's identity
that we looked at so therefore i'm just
getting oops daisy v cubed equals u
cubed times
negative one
so it's negative u cubed on the right
hand side so i'm going to add u cubed to
both sides which is which gives me this
u cubed plus v cubed right
now this is something that pahan like
immediately noticed that i did not in
tuesday's lesson you're like oh hold on
this is actually
a result that i can factorize it's a
factorization we often forget because we
don't deal with cubes very often we
spend so much time in quadratic land but
what is the factorization for sum of
cubes this is going to be
u plus v
right out the front and then does this
look familiar u squared minus u v plus
v squared and i sort of had this um
this
mnemonic device that i actually um i
said but i didn't actually explain it in
previous lesson um i used to remember
this as soap right the signs here are
same opposite always positive same
opposite always positive compared to
whatever sign you started with up the
front so this works for sum of cubes it
also works for difference of cubes um
you just get same opposite always
positive based on that being a minus
sign rather than a plus sign
okay so i've got this result here right
but you can actually say wait a second
since i know that uh you know this u
plus v
uh this u plus v part of the
factorization it can't possibly be equal
to zero why is that right think about
that if u plus v u plus v were equal to
zero then u would be equal to negative v
right
can that work can i actually get an
equilateral triangle that way um have a
think about what that means on your
eigen diagram there is a there's like a
single spot where it works but generally
speaking remember u and v can be
anywhere right so this actually locks
you into a very specific set of values
but we know there are more solutions for
u and v than just this one right so
therefore what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to say from here wow
that's the worst curly brace i've ever
tried to draw that's a little bit better
right i can actually take this part here
and say if u and v can be anywhere on
the argon diagram then this is the part
that has to be true
this part here right that's the part
that i have to say that factor has to be
able to equal zero sometimes and from
here you're like oh all i needed to do
is add uv to both sides and i'm finished
you can see except for the first two
lines of my question right up
here
or maybe maybe three lines just to be
clear
i didn't even need complex numbers for
the vast majority of the reasoning that
i was doing there i actually could get
straight into algebra and that was where
most of the work was done and that's why
actually if you have a comparison
between my two solutions there you go
this second solution is so much quicker
okay
so i'm really curious a couple people
said well you all had to go and have
different methods can anyone post in the
chat for me let me say that again can
everyone post in the chat for me
did you have one of these two methods
just say yep that was one of the ones
that i got or did someone have something
genuinely different i'm really curious
to see anybody
and they all had a different one
excellent okay jiao you had the the
first method and which was the one i
came up with first so i'm impressed
that's okay
anyone else
okay now it's
you gave me a frown vern but did it work
like i think if i have a look here yeah
you can you can do all of that in mod
arg it just takes a little bit longer to
write all of the reasoning i would say
is the same okay susie's got another one
that's great i am actually almost
finishing here so um i will just sort of
let it
if people have other methods i'd love to
see them
let me just quickly show you and i think
i should have it
uh just up here above
yeah here we go so here's what i
prepared earlier um i didn't focus too
much on the part two of the question
it's just a one mark it's relatively
simple but here is just one example
showing you that it does indeed work
because if you recall back to the
original question it says find a u and a
v for which this actually applies that
gives you an equilateral triangle
so what i did was um i i said well if i
put one up here i can use symmetry here
and be really cheap when you have a look
at my working here all this stuff down
here is not really necessary for your
one mark it just says you know tell me
what those numbers are but i just wanted
to prove my for myself that this
relation works the uv is fairly easy to
do you can see this actual actually
looks a whole lot like something that we
did just down in method two because you
get e to the i pi
over here on the left hand side it might
not be quite as obvious what i've done
so i've just written these two as um
there's u so i've got u squared here
here's v i actually should uh write that
this is
u
this is v
so
you get your u squared and your v
squared i've noticed that this result
here and i chose it for this precise
symmetry e d i 4 pi on three that's not
a principle argument is it right um
it's it's gone all the way past pi down
into the bottom half of the argan
diagram so i've rewritten it with a
principal argument and because of the
symmetry i've chosen it's e to i
negative two pi on 3 so it actually
becomes this u n minus v situation that
i was mentioning before which is just
this very specific version where it
works so because these two are
conjugates of each other
when you add if you want to think about
it this way
we don't often use our conjugate sort of
reasoning here i can think about this as
x plus iy
and x minus i y so you can see my
complex or my imaginary components
rather here they just cancel out so you
just get the two x's which is these two
real components and they're both equal
to negative a half
because it's this complex number over
here so that you get that negative one
from before
so i hope that made sense i hope this
was a question that gave you some
insight into just have a look here right
an insight into not just like oh here's
a solution method but what's the
thinking underneath it
why would you choose one formula complex
number over another in fact if you have
a look at my first method i went and i
used all of them at appropriate places
right i started with exponential codes
very succinct and i'm lazy and it makes
the arguments easier to work with but
then i had to at this point in here
translate over into mod arg into
trigonometric form to evaluate this
number and then i used the rectangular
form in here to actually accomplish this
addition and then i went back into
exponential so
this kind of flexible use of complex
numbers is often one that we miss
especially when the question gives you
no clues about which form you should use